Künstliche Intelligenz,
wenn Maschinen immer schlauer werden,
was könnten wir mit unserer
eigenen Hirnleistung machen,
wenn wir das hier
mit einer schlauen Maschine koppeln,
um so was wie ein Superintelligenz
zu erreichen?
Stellt euch vor, ihr könntet
einen Computer oder Avatar
mit euren Gedanken steuern.
Oder ihr könntet von einem Computer
neue Skills auf euer Gehirn laden.
Solche Visionen haben nicht nur
Hollywood-Filmemacher,
sondern z. B. auch Elon Musk,
der "Real Life Tony Stark".
Man kennt ihn am ehesten von Tesla
oder SpaceX.
Heute reden wir mal
über seine Firma Neuralink,
mit der er vor ein paar Monaten
dieses Pre-Print-Paper
rausgebracht hat.
Hier wird
eine neue Hardware vorgestellt,
die als Schnittstelle zwischen Gehirn
und Maschine dienen soll.
Solche Schnittstellen,
Brain Machine Interfaces genannt,
wurden aber nicht von Musk erfunden,
sondern werden schon
eine ganze Weile lang erforscht.
Sie werden übrigens genauso abgekürzt
wie der Body Mass Index, nämlich BMI.
Reden wir heute mal über
die spannendere Bedeutung von BMI.
Schauen wir uns an, was heute bereits
mit BMIs möglich ist.
Und so viel verrate ich schon mal.
Es ist mehr, als ihr denkt.
* Titelmusik *
Erst mal die Basics.
Unser Gehirn steht unter Strom.
Die Nervenzellen, die Neurone...
Vergleichen wir das mit dem Strom,
den wir aus einer Batterie kennen.
Eine geladene Batterie
steht unter elektrischer Spannung.
Das ist das,
was in Volt angegeben wird.
Diese Spannung
kann man sich vorstellen
wie ein Ungleichgewicht
zwischen elektrischen Ladungen.
Die ganzen negativ geladenen
Elektronen sitzen am Minuspol.
Am Pluspol sitzen keine.
Dadurch entsteht eine elektrische
Spannung zwischen beiden Polen.
Verbindet man jetzt die beiden Pole
mit einem Kabel,
fließen die Elektronen
vom Minuspol zum Pluspol,
um diese Spannung auszugleichen
und somit haben wir Strom.
Bei den Neuronen im Hirn
dienen Spannungsänderungen
als Signale.
Zur Übertragung von Informationen.
Es fließen zwar keine Elektronen,
aber andere geladene Teilchen.
Ionen.
Nur der Mechanismus
dieser Signalweiterleitung
ist komplexer als einfach nur Strom,
der durch ein Kabel fließt.
In der Membran der Neuronen
befinden sich kleine Kanäle.
Diese Kanäle öffnen sich,
wenn es an der Membran
einen Spannungsimpuls gibt.
Also wenn sich die Spannung
zwischen innen und außen ändert.
Durch diese geöffneten Kanäle
fließen jetzt Ionen
in die Nervenzelle hinein
und sorgen damit wieder
für ein Spannungssignal,
das benachbarte Kanäle dazu bringt,
sich zu öffnen.
Die stoßen wieder
benachbarte Kanäle an usw.
So wandert das Signal,
man sagt auch das Aktionspotential,
wie eine La-Ola-Welle
die Zellmembran entlang.
So, da jetzt Gehirnaktivität
im Grunde
auf elektrischen Spannungsimpulsen
basiert,
kann man Gehirnaktivität ablesen,
indem man
diese elektrischen Impulse misst.
Oder anders rum, man kann
Gehirnaktivität stimulieren,
indem man entsprechende Impulse
reingibt.
Genau das machen BMIs.
Dazu muss man nur Elektroden
mit einem Computer verbinden
und sich dann diese Elektroden
ins Gehirn stecken.
Diese invasive Methode
ist notwendig, um eine ausreichend
gute Auflösung zu bekommen.
Um die Signale
vieler einzelner Neurone
klar voneinander trennen zu können.
Andernfalls kann man keine
komplexen Inhalte kommunizieren.
Es gibt auch nicht-invasive Methoden,
bei denen man von außen,
also durch die Kopfhaut, den Schädel,
die Gehirnaktivität messen
oder auch beeinflussen kann.
Aber da diese Messungen
oder Stimulationen
ziemlich weit entfernt sind
von den Neuronen,
ist die Auflösung miserabel.
Man misst oder stimuliert immer
Millionen Hirnzellen gleichzeitig.
Das ist wie Tippen
mit einem Boxhandschuh.
Deshalb forscht man hauptsächlich
an invasiven Methoden.
Man hat im Gehirn zwar
kein Schmerzempfinden.
Ein Vorteil, wenn man sich
da was reinstecken möchte.
Aber ungefährlich ist es nicht,
dazu kommen wir gleich noch.
Schauen wir erst mal,
wie weit die Forschung gekommen ist.
Die Experimente sind echt abgefahren.
Stellt euch vor, ihr könntet
unsichtbare Strahlung sehen.
Ihr wisst vom Farbenvideo,
dass wir Licht nur in einem kleinen
Wellenlängenbereich sehen können.
UV-Licht oder Infrarotlicht
ist unsichtbar für uns.
Für Ratten übrigens auch.
Doch die Forschungsgruppe
rund um Neurowissenschaftler
Miguel Nicolelis
hat Ratten die Fähigkeit gegeben,
infrarotes Licht zu erfühlen.
Zunächst arbeiteten die Forscher
mit normalem sichtbaren Licht.
Sie versteckten eine Belohnung
für die Ratte bei einem Licht.
und brachten so der Ratte bei,
zum Licht zu laufen,
um sie sich zu holen.
Konnten sie den Ratten
auch beibringen,
zu einem unsichtbaren Licht
zu laufen, zu Infrarotlicht?
Dafür implantierte man den Ratten
einen Infrarotsensor auf den Kopf.
Der Computer
übersetzte das Infrarotlicht
in eine elektrische Pulsserie.
Also in künstliche Aktionspotentiale.
Je intensiver das Licht,
desto größer die Pulsfrequenz.
Diese Impulse wurden über Elektroden
in das Gehirn der Ratte übertragen.
Und zwar
in den somatosensorischen Kortex.
Das ist dieselbe Hirnregion, die auch
die Tasthaarbewegung registriert.
Der Infrarotsensor auf dem Kopf
konnte jetzt also für die Ratten
das unsichtbare Licht
durch entsprechende Hirnsignale
spürbar machen.
Dann wiederholte man mit den Ratten
das Belohnungsexperiment.
Diesmal verriet nur Infrarotlicht,
wo sich die Belohnung versteckte.
Und tatsächlich, nach einem Monat
Training konnten die Ratten dank BMI
die Belohnung
buchstäblich aufspüren.
Die Ratten bekamen somit
durch dieses Brain Machine Interface
eine Sinneserweiterung,
aber es geht noch krasser.
Diese Bewegungen
steuere ich ja alle gerade
mit meinem Gehirn.
Jetzt stellt euch vor, ich könnte
einen externen Roboterarm
wie meinen eigenen Arm
über mein Gehirn steuern.
Es gibt ein Experiment,
das schon 2003 durchgeführt wurde,
aber immer noch
der absolute Mind Blow ist.
Die Forscher brachten einem Affen
ein einfaches Computerspiel bei,
bei dem er einen Roboterarm
über einen Joystick bewegen musste.
Die Forscher zeichneten nun
die Bewegungen des Joysticks
zusammen mit der Gehirnaktivität
des Affen auf.
Ein Machine-Learning-Algorithmus
lernte nun,
welche Joystick-Bewegung mit
welcher Hirnaktivität korrelierte.
Und irgendwann konnte der Computer
die Gehirnaktivität lesen.
Also er konnte
auf Basis der Hirnaktivität
die Joystickbewegung voraussagen.
Dass das auch funktioniert,
konnten die Forscher zeigen,
indem sie den Joystick
vom Roboterarm trennten,
So dass der Arm nicht mehr durch
den Joystick gesteuert werden konnte.
Stattdessen koppelten die Forscher
den Roboterarm
direkt an das Gehirn des Affen.
Über diese Schnittstelle, die eben
Hirnsignale in Bewegung übersetzte.
Und so konnte der Affe
das Spiel weiterspielen.
Noch krasser ist, dass der Affe
nach einer Zeit merkte,
dass er den Joystick
gar nicht mehr braucht
und dass er seinen Spielarm
unabhängig davon bewegen konnte
und spielte das Spiel ganz einfach
mit seinen Gedanken weiter.
Mit mir hätte dieses Experiment
auf jeden Fall nicht funktioniert,
weil ich nie
auf die Idee kommen würde,
dass ich irgendwas
ohne meine Hände bewegen kann.
Der Affe hingegen so:
"Ach, den Joystick brauch ich nicht.
Gut, dann spiel ich das Spiel
mit meinen Gedanken weiter."
Im ersten Beispiel haben wir gesehen,
dass eine Ratte ein Eingangssignal
von einem BMI
als Anweisung interpretieren kann,
was sie jetzt tun soll.
Im zweiten Beispiel
konnte ein Affe lernen,
eine Prothese via Hirnanweisung
zu bedienen,
indem er eine entsprechende
Rückmeldung bekam, also ein Feedback.
Jetzt kombinieren wir
diese zwei Prinzipien,
um zwei Tiere
über ein Brain Machine Interface
miteinander zu verknüpfen.
In diesem spektakulären Experiment
schaffte man so was
wie eine Gedankenübertragung
zwischen zwei Raten.
Die Ratten saßen in verschiedenen
Boxen und konnten sich nicht sehen.
Ratte Nr. 1
setzte man vor zwei Hebel,
von denen sie einen drücken musste,
um eine Belohnung zu erhalten.
Ein Licht zeigte der Ratte an,
welchen Hebel sie drücken sollte
und wenn sie den richtigen drückte,
bekam sie die Belohnung.
Die Hirnaktivität von Ratte Nr. 1
wurde über Elektroden
von einem Computer aufgezeichnet
und in Spannungssignale umgesetzt,
also in Anweisungen für Ratte Nr. 2.
Die saß in der anderen Box,
hatte auch zwei Hebel vor sich
und eine mögliche Belohnung.
Nur sie hatte kein Licht, das zeigte,
welcher Hebel der richtige war.
Stattdessen bekam sie
die entsprechenden Pulssignale
der anderen Ratte
via Elektrode in ihr Gehirn gesendet.
Sie musste das interpretieren,
also lernen,
welcher Hebel der richtige ist.
Jetzt darf man nicht denken, dass die
Ratte da sitzt, die Signale bekommt
und sofort checkt:
"Ah, ja, rechts ist die Belohnung."
Wir können eigentlich
gar nicht nachvollziehen,
wie sich diese Gedankeneingabe
für die Ratte anfühlt.
Aber durch Training
kann die Ratte lernen,
diese Impulse,
die sie von dem BMI bekommt,
zu unterscheiden
und mit den Hebeln zu verknüpfen.
Also so ähnlich wie die Ratte
mit dem Infrarotsensor
lernt,
diese Impulse zu interpretieren.
Aber noch krasser ist eigentlich,
dass auch Ratte Nr. 1
mit der Zeit lernt,
ihre Hirnanweisungen
immer präziser zu geben.
Genauso wie der Affe
mit der Zeit lernt,
den Roboterarm
immer präziser zu bedienen.
Wenn Ratte Nr. 2 nämlich
den richtigen Hebel drückte,
dann bekam Ratte Nr. 1
eine zweite Belohnung.
Diese Belohnung
diente als Feedback für diese Ratte,
die so lernen konnte, ein immer
deutlicheres Signal rauszugeben.
Beide Ratten passten also ihre
Gehirnaktivität und ihr Verhalten
an diese BMI-gestützte Verbindung an.
Das waren jetzt nur drei
von vielen Beispielen.
Es gibt inzwischen
einige faszinierende
und erfolgreiche Versuche mit BMIs.
Heißt das,
wir stehen kurz vor dem Durchbruch?
Forschung und Theorie
alles faszinierend, keine Frage.
Nur wie lässt sich das alles nun
wirklich auf die Praxis übertragen?
Hier gibt es drei Probleme.
Bei unseren Forschungsbeispielen
wurden sehr komplexe Signale
von sehr vielen Neuronen
in ein stark vereinfachtes
Ausgangssignal übersetzt.
Oder andersrum, es wurden
sehr stark vereinfachte Pulsmuster
auf ganz viele Neuronen
gleichzeitig übertragen.
Und trotz der starken Vereinfachung
brauchten die Tiere
monatelanges Training,
um sicher mit den BMIs umzugehen.
Die Vision, dass wir mit unserem
Gehirn komplexe Maschinen steuern,
dass wir uns mit einer
virtuellen Realität verbinden,
miteinander sprachlos kommunizieren
oder über ein BMI eine neue Sprache
auf unser Gehirn laden,
davon sind wir derzeit
noch sehr weit entfernt.
Wir tippen vielleicht nicht mehr
mit dem Boxhandschuh,
aber mit Fäustlingen.
Herkömmliche Schnittstellen
wie unsere Sprache,
unsere Hände, unsere Sinnesorgane,
mit denen wir miteinander oder auch
mit Computern kommunizieren,
sind viel effizienter und komplexer
als die modernsten BMIs.
Für Menschen,
die aber z. B. gelähmt sind,
können auch sehr einfache Funktionen
einen großen Unterschied
für die Lebensqualität machen.
Beispiel: Jenn Sherman.
Sie ist vom Hals abwärts gelähmt.
2012 nahm sie sehr enthusiastisch
an einem Forschungsprojekt
der University of Pittsburgh teil,
in dem ein BMI-gesteuerter Roboterarm
für Menschen entwickelt wurde.
Hier sieht man Jenn, wie sie
mithilfe eines implantierten BMIs
so einen Roboterarm steuert,
um wieder selber essen zu können.
Aber hier gibt es
das zweite große Problem.
Ein dauerhaftes Implantat
kann gesundheitliche Probleme
verursachen.
Das Implantat von Jenn Sherman z. B.
musste
nach einer Zeit entfernt werden,
weil sich die Kopfhaut
um einen der Sockel zurückzog
und die Drähte entblößt wurden.
Das wurde zu einem Infektionsrisiko
für ihr Gehirn.
Brain Machine Interfaces sind ohnehin
nur eine Zeitlang nutzbar.
Ein Grund dafür
sind die starren Elektroden,
die mit jeder Bewegung des Gehirns,
ja, das Gehirn bewegt sich ständig
passiv im Kopf,
zu kleinen Verletzungen
und Narbenbildung führen.
Und das wachsende Narbengewebe
kann die Elektrode
mit der Zeit isolieren,
so dass sie den Kontakt verliert.
Elon Musk und Neuralink
wollen das Problem
mit sogenannten "Electrode Threads"
lösen.
Das sind besonders dünne
und flexible Elektroden,
die sich, so die Hoffnung,
mit dem Gehirn mitbewegen.
Zur Implantierung
dienen außerdem Roboter,
die immerhin an der Hirnoberfläche
Verletzungen von Blutgefäßen
vermeiden können.
Allerdings wurde bisher
noch nicht erwähnt,
wie lange diese Electrode Threads
in ihren bisherigen Versuchen
tatsächlich hielten.
Es gibt auch semi-invasive Methoden.
Z. B. kann man Scheiben implantieren.
Die werden flach
auf die Hirnhaut aufgelegt,
dringen aber nicht ins Gehirn ein.
Mit so einem System
kann dieser 28-jährige
querschnittsgelähmte Franzose
nun schon seit zwei Jahren
ein Exoskelett steuern.
Mehr Infos dazu
in der Videobeschreibung.
Allerdings für den Austausch
detaillierter Informationen,
mit hoher Bandbreite,
wie Elon Musk sich das wünscht,
ist die Auflösung
so eines semi-invasiven Systems
nicht ausreichend.
Aber es gilt aus Proof of concept,
dass auch Langzeitanwendungen
in der Prothesensteuerung
möglich sind.
Das könnte Menschen
mit Querschnittslähmung
ihre Mobilität zurückgeben.
Nur dabei sollten wir auch ein paar
ethische Aspekte nicht vergessen.
Ich vermute mal,
die wenigsten von euch würden sich
Elektroden ins Gehirn
implantieren lassen,
"nur" um eine Sinneserweiterung
oder andere Spielereien zu erfahren.
Und selbst
eine extrem coole Anwendung...
Sagen wir, ich könnte über ein BMI
alle Sprachen sprechen.
Das ist wie gesagt nicht möglich,
aber sagen wir, das wäre es.
Das wäre ja der Hammer,
aber würde ich mir dafür ernsthaft
die Schädeldecke öffnen
und Elektroden
ins Gehirn stecken lassen?
Es würde mich jetzt nicht wundern,
wenn Elon Musk das wirklich
machen würde, aber ...
die meisten von uns würden sich
wahrscheinlich keiner OP unterziehen,
wenn es keinen ernsthaften
medizinischen Bedarf gibt.
Zumal ja jede OP
auch mit einem Risiko einhergeht.
Aber wenn es jetzt um Anwendungen
für Menschen mit Behinderung geht,
die dadurch ihre Mobilität
zurückgewinnen könnten,
würden die meisten wohl sagen,
das ist doch super, diese Anwendung,
die Forschung muss man unterstützen.
Ich habe mit Aktivist
Raul Krauthausen gesprochen,
der sich für Menschen
mit Behinderung einsetzt.
Meine Perspektive
auf das ganze Thema ist halt,
dass man sehr vorsichtig sein muss
mit solchen Meldungen
und auch Technologien.
Die Person, die die Behinderung hat,
wird dafür verantwortlich gemacht,
die Behinderung
aus der Welt zu schaffen.
Indem sie operiert wird,
indem sie Therapie macht,
indem sie ein Exoskelett trägt.
Und wir stellen viel zu wenig
die Frage,
wie könnte auch
eine Gesellschaft aussehen,
in der es okay ist,
wenn man eben nicht laufen kann,
wenn man eben nicht hören kann.
Also z. B. indem
mehr Gebärdensprache benutzt wird,
indem wir
Aufzüge und Rampen usw. bauen
oder bei Netflix untertiteln.
Dass wir durch solche Technologien
ja auch Barrieren beseitigen können
um Menschen, so wie sie sind,
an der Gesellschaft
teilhaben zu lassen.
Trotzdem bin ich ein großer Freund
von technologischem Fortschritt.
Auch ich selber
fahre einen elektrischen Rollstuhl,
der besser ist
als ein manueller Rollstuhl.
Weil ich einfach auch
aufgrund meiner Behinderung
und meiner Kraft niemals mit einem
manuellen Rollstuhl so weit käme,
wie ich
mit dem elektrischen Rollstuhl komme.
Aber auch da, genauer geguckt,
ist das traurige Technologie da drin.
Da gibt es null Innovation.
Es gibt immer nur da Innovation,
wo Geld ist.
Ich als Aktivist
für Inklusion und Barrierefreiheit
bekomme regelmäßig Links geschickt
von Leuten, die meinen,
mir was Gutes zu tun,
indem sie z. B.
mir einen Link schicken
von einem treppensteigenden Rollstuhl
oder einem Handschuh,
der Gebärdensprache
in Ton oder Text übersetzt.
All diese Technologien
sind megafancy.
Aber sie sind
nicht unbedingt günstig.
Die Krankenkasse würde das
wahrscheinlich nicht bezahlen.
Das heißt auch hier, durch diese
neuen Technologien überlassen wir
letztendlich diese ganzen Geschichten
nur den Privilegierten, den Reichen.
Wie seht ihr das?
Würdet ihr euch Implantate
ins Gehirn einsetzen lassen?
Was wäre die coolste Anwendung
eines BMI, die euch einfällt?
Wir sehen uns bald.
Bis dahin, bleibt sicher.
Untertitel: ARD Text
im Auftrag von Funk (2019)